la cifra de contagios a causa de la
competición 9º para de aumentar en los
países de la unión europea la oms ya
considera a europa como el epicentro de
la pandemia de nuevo porque no sólo
preocupan los contagios sino sobre todo
las muertes y también las
hospitalizaciones a pesar de que más del
70 por ciento de los adultos de la unión
europea están vacunados esta cifra no es
suficiente pero algunos países ni
siquiera se acercan como por ejemplo
alemania o austria este último
precisamente quiere aplicar un
confinamiento a las personas no
vacunadas tampoco podrán acceder ni a
restaurantes ni haberes aman a menos que
enseñen un certificado de vacunación
países bajos también aplicará nuevas
restricciones para evitar los contactos
sociales y también prohibirá a la
asistencia de personas a los eventos
deportivos bélgica también intenta
aplicar nuevas restricciones a finales
de este mes a medida que siguen subiendo
las hospitalizaciones y también los
contagios pero la peor parada sin duda
es europa del este- países como por
ejemplo bulgaria que apenas superan el
20% de vacunados están sufriendo
seriamente la saturación de los
hospitales de hecho la presidenta de la
comisión europea úrsula von der leyen no
ha dudado en decir en que europa se
encuentra ante una pandemia de no
vacunados